bruce arians one of one of the more
underrated coaches in the nfl a guy who
didn't get his opportunity to be a head
coach until 2013 because he's a little
rough and tumble he's a little in your
face he's a little tell it like it is
and
sometimes owners don't want guys telling
them like it is and that's what he's
always done and now he's coaching a
super bowl for the first time
helps to have tom brady helps to have
the foresight to get tom brady on the
team helps to have the team in place
that would attract to tom brady jason
light the gm of the team deserves some
credit for that but their signature
victory came sunday at lambeau field
against the green bay packers 31-26
chris took a lurk a look at the film and
let's focus first on tom brady and his
performance because
it it really was different
in the second half yeah what when do you
ever see any quarterback much less brady
throw interceptions on three straight
possessions and if it was any other
quarterback that did it we would
collectively be calling for that guy to
be ejected from the league for good well
that's that's what's crazy is because
you know first off the way you started
the game we kind of hit that yesterday
that that was amazing for a team that we
talked about had not been there you know
not a lot of big playoff games never
been in a super bowl as far as a lot of
the guys on the team i think other than
jpp maybe i'm missing one other player
you know the way he came out and just
made some big third down throws early
that at least set the tone there's no
doubt about that you know
and and you know down the field throws
not like hey we're looking on third and
three to get four yards to fade down the
left sideline it's mike evans perfectly
thrown you know the deep out route to
godwin uh on this in the slot route you
know perfectly thrown the touchdown pass
to evans perfectly thrown so from all
those things it was great you saw them
take a chance on that jump ball in their
second scoring drive yes but at the end
of the third quarter and those three
interceptions he threw i mean that is
that is why i believe tampa has changed
the way they've played and we've talked
about this a lot during the year it's in
some of these moments we've seen where
brady gets people around him and can
just get a little flustered and he'll
just throw it up now that only happened
on one of the interceptions you know but
but either way it was
not a that would have been a monumental
collapse if they lost that game and
brady had thrown three interceptions in
the fourth quarter
that would have been something we've
never seen from brady ever in his career
so that's where it was kind of like
striking that way
yeah and i i can't help but wonder how
much of what we saw is the culmination
of 19 games of hearing
the no risk it no biscuit mantra from
bruce arians just throw the ball just
trust your receivers just throw it up
there and let them go do the work tom
you don't have to do the work all the
time you don't have to deliver a
pinpoint pass we got some good receivers
throw it up there and they'll go get it
we talked about this yesterday when we
were praising chris goblin who had over
100 receiving yards and really didn't
get noticed he had that catch where the
ball could have been intercepted oh
right god would made a great adjustment
it was almost shades of lyn swan in
super bowl 10
and i think that that emboldened tom
brady to keep taking chances the rest of
the game well um you could be right you
know all three interceptions had their
own different angle the first
interception at the very end of the
third quarter right that was just a bad
decision and bad throw there's nothing
more to that you know the second
interception was the second interception
the one where he fell down and just
threw it up or was that the third one
that was the third so the second one was
the the ball over the middle to evans
great decision he's done the ball in the
right spot he just missed the throw like
that's gonna happen but you don't see
that happen from brady a lot and it
happened a few times in the fourth
quarter and then the last one that was
i'm 43 and i don't want to be hit and
i'm just gonna throw the ball up so
that's what they have to worry about
we've seen those issues there as far as
when he gets pressured he did that to
kansas city the first time around where
he threw some bad interceptions and felt
that pressure i think of kansas city
last year when he's playing for the
patriots and he has julian edelman in
the end zone for a game tying touchdown
and here comes frank clark so tom does
the quick release fetal position don't
get you know obliterated by frank clark
right but that's what you have to do
to keep playing
into your 40s definitely can't allow
yourself
to take a square hit as a sitting duck
from a frank clark or
um you know a zadaria smith
or coming up this week frank clark again
for crying out loud you can't do it so
that's the live to fight another day
play right we've seen it happen he hopes
to throw it away remember what he did
against the steelers three years ago
right he threw that ball and he's like i
was trying to throw it away they
intercepted it i mean yeah he was trying
to throw it away but
when you when your goal is don't get
killed
uh secondary objectives become accuracy
of the throw and that's just kind of you
have to take that one radius
that's right that's right you got to
take it that's exactly it and then they
have to do their best to not have them
be in those situations right which is
what they've done they've done a great
job
making him feel comfortable
blocking things up so he can just sit
back there and go okay
i'm gonna torch you now with the pass
game and that's where they've really
found their mojo and everything like
that you know but but i think at the
bottom line you know the one thing i
just come back to at the very least when
you just break this game down right
brady gets them the jump start gets them
going and then the team is like oh okay
hey we we belong we're better than this
team let's go
it's the second year in a row i just
come away going the packers got out hit
in the championship game you know anyway
you want to talk about it they were out
hit whether it's pass rush the tampa bay
buccaneers mike ran the same running
play the whole game other than one run
they ran it was the same one it was
literally just we're going straight
ahead and we're either gonna plow you
downhill and flanner fournette's gonna
get four or five yards or you're all
gonna go in there and he'll bounce it
outside and get a few yards that way but
think about the jump ball you just
talked about green bay is in position to
get it godwin just outmans darnell
savage for the ball the next play is
fournette breaking tackles
spinning in the end zone for a 20-yard
run you know the the hit just caused a
fumble for the touchdown the hit that
caused the fumble that green bay also
recovered you know it just again it was
the second year in a row that that came
away with more than anything bruce
ariens his team
they flew around and were the team that
played with greater intensity throughout
the game if you just had to boil it down
to one thing that's what i would boil it
down to and i think that's an excellent
point who's ready to go seize the day
and who isn't and that's one of the
things that bruce aryan spoke about
yesterday at their bye week they were
seven and five
and it's not like they did major surgery
on the playbook it's not like they did
major surgery on the roster we saw
antonio brown's playing time drop after
the buy but but beyond that he just said
we we understand everybody's got to work
harder now everybody's got to want it
more now when you have 22 guys out there
on offense and defense and they are
trying harder and they are collectively
imposing their will
more effectively that you're going to
see the collective result and you know
you mentioned missed opportunities i
mean you have to take advantage in a
game like that will redmond had the ball
in his hands
kind of not he he should have had the
ball in this well yeah went right
through his two hands right before the
fourth down conversion right
and and then the scotty miller yes the
scottie miller touchdown doesn't happen
if will redmond right can catch a can of
corn from tom brady at the end of the
first half no doubt there's a
game-changing moment i mean really
there's the game had huge moments i
think the jump ball to godwin was one of
those it was a third down and nine and
it looked like whoa the packers had a
little momentum that was one of them
then the next one i do believe goes into
that second half or the end of the first
half situation right i mean
again
just that dropped interception and i
know we haven't talked about this today
and there's you know i know you wrote
something on pft yesterday about it but
i still can't quite un i i
cannot for the life of me
make logic of what green bay was trying
to do on that last play of the first
half i mean let's focus on that i mean
you've looked at it and you've studied
it well yeah i got one safety you're not
really guarding the sidelines what are
you really doing there if you're the
green bay pack that's what i don't
understand is you look at it they're
playing a defense that
okay it's a single safety they're gonna
see as we go here there's people in the
middle of the field and the guys on the
outside are the ones that are vulnerable
in a no-win one-on-one position as you
can see jair alexander's the corner to
the right on the left is kevin king so
go ahead and let it play kristen if you
can and then you see here they keep it
gronk into blocks right max protect they
make him feel good but
it basically becomes a one-on-one
match-up the first thing you want to go
is hey kevin king let them throw the 10
yard out get back but the more important
thing is you want to go
what is this defense why are we calling
this why is there not two safeties deep
they have no timeouts
you know
look at 51 and 26 what they're in no
man's land they're worried about the
back out of the backfield so what
let them throw the ball of the back out
of the backfield the half will be over
it's over that's where
it is really
um confusing about what they were
thinking there they literally played a
defense
to allow the buccaneers to get out of
bounds
and then on top of that they didn't
defend the end zone either and that to
me goes back to the coaching more than
anything
watch this again let it play again coach
dungey i think said something about this
on twitter you got inside leverage too
on the receivers why are you playing
them to the inside where the goal is you
got to keep them to the inside you're
right outside on them right it's a mic
it is literally like hey did you guys
want 10 more yards to kick a field goal
we're gonna play a defense to do that no
problem guys i mean you're you're brady
in the bucks so we're we want to be you
know nice guests i mean our nice you
know host here you go oh wait didn't you
don't want the 10 yard out you want the
touchdown oh we're a nice host go ahead
we'll let you have it that was a huge
moment of the game of course that and
then leading into the first few plays of
the the second half and mike penton the
defensive coordinator of the packers he
look don't be surprised if he's the
former defensive coordinator of the
packers matt lafleur was fairly candid
after the game about his disappointment
with what happened there i mean that was
really kind of a dagger moment and then
you had your extra dagger then you had
the extra dagger to make it 28 to 10
after the aaron jones fumble which is
what made the potential comeback
even more right uh impressive but it
should have been 24-10 that's the point
it should be 24-10 even if those things
happen right that touchdown pass was a
preventable thing that was very easy if
there was just basic football logic with
that one which there wasn't and that
extra four points as we saw was the
difference in the football game that was
that was it the drop two point
conversion made it the five point game
right
now and one of the reasons why the
buccaneers held on to the lead as tom
brady was melting down in the second
half and it is okay folks to say it
really is i'm telling you anybody out
there who works in sports media
lightning will not strike you dead if
you say tom brady played poorly in the
second half of the game it's just a
twitter mob everybody's scared you're
allowed to say that he was bad you can
be the announcer and you you can be on
any show you can be the right you can be
any anyone in the media it's okay to say
that that the goat wasn't the goat he
was more like a real goat he was a goat
in the bad way that giraffe's coming up
later today maybe he's going to make it
to the goats in the bad weight draft
today but
when he had the second and third
interception chris
the packers
didn't do anything with it no no they
could have actually turned this into
like not quite a
not quite a chiefs texans turn around
flipping around route
but they could have won the game by
seven or ten points if they had managed
to cash in on all the mistakes tom brady
was making
no doubt mike but you know what it came
down to like once again it really went
back to the old thing that we just
talked about and those moments there
were green bay yeah you know they got a
little momentum they got the ball down
28-23
you know what happened they got out hit
again the buccaneers pass rush kind of
took over the game look at if you're
looking at the graphic here 12 20 first
and ten of the green bay 19. rogers has
a post route by devante adams and he has
marquez valdez scaling going across the
field wide open for a 25-yard gain if
roger just throws the ball in the
vicinity and it's gonna be a huge game
he can't ever settle because he has
pressure from the get-go so he tries to
throw the ball up if you remember and
kind of gets hit as he throws the ball
flutters into the air to no man's land
incomplete but that was you know again
there's a play there to be had but they
were out physical second drive as you
see first play
sack behind the chains
and then it became throw throw and they
couldn't really protect or get open in
those moments either and they had to
drop ball i think on third down over the
middle of the lazard on that second
series there so yeah you know rogers
said it yesterday they had their chances
they definitely did they didn't
capitalize and then they also mess
things up themselves that it's going to
be hard to sleep and get over this one
why weren't the packers now look they
don't have david bogtiari but the
offensive line had looked very good the
prior week against the la ramps yeah why
couldn't they handle shaq barrett and
jpp
the it's fun you know that's why it's
always funny with like a match-up sport
right mike yeah leonard floyd some of
the rams guys that come off the edge
they're smaller speed type guys right
jpp is a 290 pound defensive end shaq
barrett you know 275 but power based i
mean you know mike my kind of guys here
legs and ass they're going to push
people back so it was a tougher matchup
for
you know a guy like billy turner who's a
guard he's not your typical left tackle
he got overpowered just straight up you
know you hear the phrase push the pocket
that was a big key and then
you know the other key
is
vita velya him being that pushing the
pocket up the middle was another issue
for green bay too
but yeah they struggled blocking that
group and todd bowles did a good job of
just hey letting his front four do work
but occasionally sending a fifth man
just to make sure everybody got
one-on-one and now his guys could go to
work but that course was a big part of
the battle as them winning that battle
up front and you could see that turner
was under extra pressure because he was
doing everything he could to get a
little bit of a split second yeah he
jumped a few times right to the point
where there were some uncalled false
starts by billy turner and hey if they
don't call it good for you but he was
getting he was getting back into his his
stance to brace for the onslaught a
little bit early to try to better
protect aaron rodgers and uh you know
ultimately didn't work i mean the guy
got sacked five times you just don't see
that happen no on a regular basis to
hear rogers he had no words why don't we
yeah why didn't we hear about the the
packers great defensive players zadaria
smith preston smith rashawn gary right
why weren't they why weren't they uh
called out that's where like like right
i texted you yesterday right like we got
done with the show and i said the one
thing we didn't talk about is like we
talked about all these bucks guys who
popped out and to the overall theme
again of what we're talking about and
being out hit as a football team right
just to boil it down to one basic thing
and yeah that they lost that battle too
they lost that's why you know i think
this is why you and i picked the bucks
to win the football game yes we know one
team was thirteen and three and the
other one was eleven and five i had
people like on twitter yesterday like
how could you say they were better when
one team was the one seed in the uh well
because at this moment they're better
across the board i mean it does you
offensive line it's a close one it's
close but we're taking tampa they were
better the defensive line not even a
question tampa linebackers tampa
secondary okay close all right now let's
go to offense wide receivers not not
close tampa
running backs all right close one there
i mean so yes tampo is a really good
football team and they stonewalled that
that green bay pass rush they didn't get
even close to brady other than that one
interception where he threw the ball up
in the air but for the most part of the
day he had great protection and was able
to see the field and step into a lot of
throws
zadaria smith when he joined us in miami
i know i knew you're gonna hear the
super bowl week here's the quote and
this is his assessment
of the nfc championship game last year
where it wasn't even close they got
steamrolled by the 49ers he said we
didn't come ready to play i don't know
if everybody was sleeping but i can tell
you for myself
i wasn't ready to play
either now i'm not ready to come to that
conclusion as it relates to this nfc
championship game maybe they were ready
to play they didn't have to travel they
were at home but
something was missing there was a
physicality that was missing there was a
a sense of being opportunistic that was
missing the bucks had it and the packers
didn't
and in a league where the talent
gap is narrower than ever exactly
that's going to be the difference
between winning and losing the nfc
championship game that's going to be the
difference between winning and losing
the super bowl potentially for whichever
team is ready to be opportunistic and
take advantage of the things that come
their way yeah it's exactly right you
know again this is
the game has become all about big plays
that's what it is and as we saw the
other day there you know tampa made more
of them there's no doubt about that
that's really what it is i mean the
turnovers
the touchdowns the
okay gotta have it third down moments in
the red zone hey they stopped green bay
from scoring touchdowns made them kick
field goals those are huge moments in
the football game and like you said it
perfectly in this gay day and age with
two teams in the nfc championship who
are very evenly matched it's the team
who can make a few plays and the team
who makes a few mistakes that's really
all it boils down for for for most of
the time and and that was clearly
advantage tampa in that one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports